des bustes des corps des têtes des
sculptures signées auguste rodin est
issu de la collection du musée rodin à
paris
à côté d'elle des oeuvres de georges
jean claud l'un des artistes permanents
de la galerie capazza cette exposition
est le fruit de trois années de travail
en collaboration avec le musée rodin
nous est venue le désir commun de
rapprocher les oeuvres d'auguste rodin
immense sculpteur et celle de georges
jean claud qui a énormément marqué
l'histoire de la sculpture au 20e
modeler le vivant c'est le nom de
l'exposition les oeuvres de rodin et de
jean claud se répondent dans un dialogue
sur la matière le bronze pour rodin la
terre cuite pour jean-claude les deux
artistes ont en commun d'avoir mis la
nature et l'humain au coeur de leur
travail de création
jean claud et rodin deux artistes qui
ont travaillé sur l'humain sur la
condition humaine sur la force
expressive en cherchant toujours d'aller
au plus juste aux niveaux
de la recherche formelle on est dans une
figuration qui n'est pas appuyé on est
dans une force énergie une expression
qui dépasse qui nous dépasse et qui nous
transforme
[Musique]
l'exposition réunit une trentaine
d'oeuvres
elle est à découvrir jusqu'à la fin
septembre
[Musique]